we all knew it was coming when Nvidia
announced the GTX 1080 last year there
was already speculation that the GTX
1080 TI would launch
shortly and I guess they were running on
valve time though in their defense that
is still quite a bit better than AMD
time at this point so here we are then
10 months later and we finally got the
latest Titan killer from Nvidia and at
rough
half the cost get
[Music]
amped hp's new Omen X lineup comes
equipped with Intel's 7th generation
core i7 processor check it out at the
link in the video
description so the GPU Market has been
pretty quiet lately and for good reason
there just hasn't really been much in
the way of direct competition between
our beloved red and green Giants since
Nvidia has stuck to the high end for
their 160 nanometer product launches and
amd's been busy building out their
mid-range and budget lineup thankfully
for those of us who are interested in
the high-end Nvidia has graciously
decided that they're just Plum old sick
of selling gp102 video cards for over
$1,000 and turned it up to 11 with the
GTX 1080 TI the founders Edition flavor
of which they've sent over for our
evaluation it's got 11 gigs of gddr 5x
memory at 11 gbit per second ah I see
what they did there which is 1 gab less
than the Titan XP but at a higher speed
to substantially increased memory
throughput good thing too because we go
from a 384-bit memory bus down to
352bit it has the same number of Cuda
cores at
3584 and while they share the same
transistor count of 12 million the 1080
TI's cores boost up to a rated 1582 MHz
instead of
1531 so far so good but what the 1080 TI
lacks compared to the Titan XP and I
mean aside from the DVI port that they
ditched in favor of more exhaust room
for the fan is RS I mean to be clear it
has them just fewer we go from 96 down
to 88 while also losing 256 kilobytes of
level 2 cash which is a part of what
allows Nvidia to build the 1080 TI for
less but how is that going to affect
performance is it possible that this
time Titan XP owner ERS will get to
continue to enjoy a performance
Advantage however small in return for
that Hefty early adopter tax they paid
well in our lineup is the Titan XP the
new kids little brother GTX 1080 the
last gen GTX 980 TI that it directly
replaces and for Giggles since you can't
even really buy one we've also included
amd's fastest GPU to date the Radeon R9
Fury X so that then is business as usual
but wait there's something different our
Intel test bench we'll have a core i7
7700k and our AMD test bench whoa two
test
benches we'll have a ryzen 7 1800x on a
gigabyte orus ax370 gaming 5 because Max
dropped our Asus Crosshair 6 no why both
you might ask well because if you've
been waiting for ryzen and the GTX 1080
TI to drop in order to start your next
upgrade or new build well you're
probably also waiting for benchmarks
that combine the two so don't worry then
hypothetical viewer we've got you
covered we'll kick things off with DSX
mankind divided indirect X11 on the AMD
platform our 1080 TI was neck and neck
with the Titan XP and on our Intel bench
actually Beat It Out moving into DirectX
12 we see the Nvidia lineup stumble
somewhat with the 1080 TI appearing to
take one of the smallest hits along with
the Titan XP meanwhile the fury X gained
some frames good news for all the
Forward Thinking AMD users out there
Rise of the Tomb Raider in direct X11
mode sees the 1080ti pull ahead of the
pack on the Intel system while it falls
slightly behind on AMD with this story
ending about the same way that DSX did
with a modest performance drop in
directx12 mode in for Honor on the other
hand the 1080ti pulls ahead on both test
benches with the older 980 TI and fury X
virtually tied at the bottom and Grand
Theft Auto 5 tells the same Gangland
tale though it clearly favors the extra
threads available on ryzen with a
significantly higher minimum frame rate
on that platform versus Intel Doom
meanwhile found the opposite was true
ripping and tearing with fewer threads
and placing our 1080 TI in both tests
within the margin of error of the Titan
XP rounding out our game tests then is
Crisis 3 which seemed to perform about
on par between our platforms and exactly
the same on our ryzen
bench 3D Mark pitches in for our
synthetic benchmarks here finding the
1080 TI at the top of the pile in both
fir strike Ultra and time spy and our
ryzen bench performing better overall
thanks to 3D Mark favoring higher core
counts over per thread performance at
least to a point the 1080 TI matches our
Titan xp's thermals pretty closely which
in spite of nvidia's marketing about two
times larger airflow path which doesn't
really work that way is no surprise
given that it runs the same gp102 GPU
and is rated at the same 250 W TDP we
found that it idled slightly warmer than
the Titan XP while at full burn it
maintained 85° at 2300 to 2385 MHz on
the core thanks to GPU Boost
2.0 okay then so clearly the 1080 TI is
a powerful card though at
$700 like it freaking better be more
importantly is it a good value well
compared to the Titan XP it certainly is
but then again what wouldn't be
so how does it hold up against the rest
of our test stable well to find out
we've compiled the average FPS for each
of our game tests then divided the
available cards by their brand new price
or the unavailable ones by the going
rate on eBay as well as the last price
we can find for them new so on both test
benches the 1080 TI FPS per dollar works
out to about
84 very similar actually a little better
than the GTX 1080 TI with the 980 TI and
the fury X both looking great if you're
buying them used but definitely not as
good if you uh go by what we used to
have to pay for that kind of performance
which I suppose gives us our conclusion
then at 699 us the 1080 TI is only cheap
if you wipe your butt with AMD RX 480s
and game on a recreation of the
compensator 2.0 but it trades blows with
the Titan XP as the fastest video card
we've ever seen and more importantly it
actually holds its own when it comes to
FPS per dollar to not perhaps compared
to lower tier products like the
aforementioned rx480 but certainly among
other top tier gpus which is pretty cool
if you want to have a beautiful website
for only $12 a month and if you sign up
for a year you get a domain for free you
can get Squarespace they also offer 24/7
live chat and email support your website
will look beautiful with Technologies
like responsive design that make your
website look great on any device even
watches and stuff they also have
Commerce modules if you need to sell
your wares through your website and
cover page features if you just want one
simple web page that someone can scroll
through that you can set up in a matter
of minutes and now everyone can post
content in the Apple news format
directly from their Squarespace blog
module start a trial with no credit card
required and start building your website
today so thanks for watching guys
dislike or like uh check out where to
buy the stuff we featured at the link in
the video description uh usually we'll
have an Amazon link down there so go
check it out also down there is our
merch store and our community Forum
which you should totally join if you
want to go talk Tech with other
enthusiasts now that you're done doing
all that stuff you're probably wondering
what to watch next so check out our
latest video or some of some video and
there will be a box you can click on it